- Wonderful. Well, thanks
for joining us, everybody.
Either you're very
interested in the journey
to the autonomous
enterprise, or you're lost.
Either way, we appreciate you being here.
I'm super excited to be
with Mark from Genworth.
We'll go into a little
bit of our background
and talk about what we're
seeing in the market,
more specifically how
Genworth is optimizing
some of their enterprise
business process workflows
through Amazon Connect
and some of the other AWS technologies.
Cool, so you wanna start with your intro?
- Yeah, Mark Downey.
I started at Genworth about 13 years ago.
I currently own the telecom
and now most recently the
AWS Connect experience.
And yeah.
- Awesome.
- Great.
- My name's Matt Arellano
I'm a senior vice president,
helped to lead the Amazon Business Group,
AWS Business Group for Genpact.
My background's about 22 years management,
technology, consulting.
I was actually acquired into Genpact.
I was fortunate enough to be a president
and co-founder of a firm
that they acquired a few months ago.
And before that I led
the global strategy team
in another large GSI,
but always around data, business process,
at the intersection of
artificial intelligence.
So look forward to the conversation today.
Awesome, so a couple
topics we wanna talk about.
So we're gonna cover off on the journey
to the autonomous enterprise.
Help to define what
autonomy ultimately is.
I think that's a somewhat
of a contested conversation these days
as it relates to how much autonomy,
where the human actually sits
within the conversation
around agents within the loop,
the collaborator with the agents,
and touch on modernization and
what it means to modernize.
Mark's gonna go into some detail
around how Genworth modernized
their infrastructure
and some of their core business processes.
Talk about real-world autonomy in action.
Talk about the leadership mindset shift.
We're seeing obviously much of
this push from the top down.
I think 12 months ago it was
very much so a board directive.
I think it still is,
but now it's starting to
trickle down to line of business
and how do you optimize your
business process from copilot
all the way through truly
agentic-based business processes.
Answer some questions,
and then talk about the future
and some closing takeaways.
So with that, the journey to autonomy.
So setting the stage here.
So over the course of the last, let's say,
seven to ten years, I believe
most of you in the room,
our customers, and excuse me, Genworth,
have moved from migration.
You've seen this migration of
your legacy application estate
and your data estate
into the cloud, right?
Providing that scalability, resiliency,
governance, control, and optimization.
As we think about moving
towards this modernized state,
we believe this opportunity
of modernization
access this runway,
and autonomy allows you
kind of to take off,
to truly rethink from a
first principle perspective,
your business processes.
So unencumbered,
taking away some of those legacy SOPs
and really transforming.
And that's how you can optimize process.
That's how you can get
towards this future state of autonomy.
We did some primary research.
We're actually gonna
release it in January.
So I hope we have the opportunity
to send to everybody here.
And from there, what we actually found,
which I find fairly compelling,
is about 12% of the senior
execs that we spoke with
believe they're on the path
towards autonomy with AI embedded, scaled,
and ultimately governed
across their business.
So that might seem like
actually a high number,
but I think as you have
been across the conference
over the last two days,
you heard agents about 4,000 times.
And we'll continue to hear them
over the course of the next three days.
I think most organizations
probably would think they're on that path,
but it's definitely something that is,
I believe we're all looking to achieve.
But the opportunity to get there,
there's many steps in,
that need to be in place,
of which Mark will talk
about how Genworth got there.
So moving from AI-assisted
to this concept of autonomy.
So what we're seeing in the rise,
so what is this autonomous enterprise?
So multi-agent, this ecosystem,
the keynote this morning,
talk about ecosystem of capabilities,
aging core with things like observability,
the learning model,
some of the recursive
nature of these models,
I think is fairly compounding
in the effect of those.
The management of complex workflows,
I'll talk about first
principles a few times.
But the ability to truly
build with first principles
I think is fairly compelling.
So as you think about leveraging agents,
try to take that first principle approach.
You can manage kind of
the existing processes
that you have and rebuild
with first principles
and see where there's points of friction
with compliance and
regulatory and security teams.
Responsibility by design,
so from the infrastructure,
data, model layer,
all the way through the outcome,
you really need to think
about the responsibility
and how having regulatory and compliance
have a seat at the table,
working with a large banking customer.
And most of their agentic use
cases actually get filtered
through their compliance team to start,
just to make sure that they understand
the regulatory posture
and the potential risk
before they deploy these agents.
AI is a collaborator and not a manager.
I think this is really important.
So AI and human as a collaborator.
So bringing those two tenants together
and making sure you
understand how the human
and the agent need to work together
and having the off-ramps necessary.
So when the probabilistic
nature of these outcomes
and the answers really need to be governed
and managed by humans.
And finally always on, always
learning, so on and so forth.
But the path towards
this concept of autonomy
we believe takes three stages, right?
It's really three phases.
Most of you are probably
familiar with the first one,
which is the copilot, right?
But it's hard to bank
returns of a copilot.
So what's 10% of your efficiency in a day,
the compounding effect
of that 10% across your 50,000 employees,
it's hard to kind of underwrite
that return from a CFO perspective.
So while that's unlocking knowledge,
it's unlocking the experience
of most individuals.
I think for the office of the CFO,
and as you think about presenting this
to the street or your shareholders,
it's very much so hard.
But by contrast,
we're starting to see the acceleration
of vertical use cases at
the departmental level
and multi-agent workflows
at the enterprise level
that are truly targeting
measurable outcomes.
So whether it's the
return of bad debt, right,
whether it's the optimization of agents,
right, of call activity,
it really becomes important.
So what you measure
determines that answer.
And the returns should also include
this concept of AI fluency,
or actually the capability compounds
across thousands of tasks.
So that sets the stage for
this P&L impact that, you know,
I believe is in phase two
and three of this journey.
So most people start with
the copilot use cases,
which I think are fairly impactful,
but that opportunity to
bank returns for your CFO
and show that we're actually
optimizing the business
I think is something that most
organizations aspire towards.
And we see that in kind of
the second and third phase,
which is vertical use cases
and then kind of into this
full end-to-end agentic.
But Mark, for you, within Genworth-
- Yeah.
- How are you guys seeing
kind of the agent experience?
- Yeah, so you know, it's exactly that.
We started copilot,
and it's really testing the waters, right?
And you see a lot of that.
But those early wins start to
build that snowball towards,
okay, now, where else can we use it?
Who else has it, you
know, in a native way?
And, you know, how I'm thinking about it
is a lot with how do we enable our agents
to have a much more human experience
with the callers, right?
There are customers, policy holders.
We wanna make sure that when they call us,
they're not sitting through,
you know, tippity tap, ah, my
computer's slow, I'm sorry.
And, you know, that's
always been a frustration
with that caller experience.
The caller never makes that
connection to our agents.
And, you know, what we've been able to do
and what we're looking to
do as the journey goes on
is have the AI fetch all
of that data ahead of time.
You know, we start with
when the caller comes in,
we've identified 'em, we
know their policy number,
start pulling all that,
getting that, you know,
all of the previous call history in line.
And then, you know, when the agent starts,
they kind of have that
right in front of them
in a way that they haven't before.
- It's interesting.
We spent some time with the
Connect team earlier today,
and they were talking
about leveraging Connect,
not only just for kinda
the agent experience,
but effectuating kind of the
end-to-end business process.
So whether for a
healthcare company driving
towards the collection
of appeals information.
So really using that agent
to augment the human in many cases,
take it all the way through
kind of the last mile.
So you guys experiencing that?
- Yeah, absolutely.
And that, and we're seeing that, you know,
particularly on the claims
side where, you know,
the claims are sent in electronically
and we can actually
take anywhere, you know,
it used to be three weeks to pay a claim.
Now we're down to a matter of days
because we can identify, you know, oh,
this is duplicate, this
is potential fraud.
We can find all those early
and get those in front of a human,
but the vast majority of
'em were able to just say,
yeah, you know, that can be paid.
That's normal claim, right?
- Yeah. That's amazing.
We were speaking to a
healthcare client most recently,
and their biggest fear
was the external and internal agent clash.
So you have an authorization on one side,
the agent produces the authorization,
helps to orchestrate
that on the other end.
You have the denial, right?
- Yeah.
- So you just keep going back and forth
and the agent keeps prepping information
and resubmitting it,
and the other agent keeps denying it
based on some level of
medical information.
So do you guys have any of
that experience or occasion?
- Not as yet.
You know, for, you know,
once we run it through the
process, it's really, you know,
that final eyes on it,
human eyes, that we'll say,
and we don't send, you know,
any of that back through.
It's, agent has said, you
know, it goes, it goes.
- Got it.
- So yeah.
- Cool.
- Making sure
that human in the loop has the final say.
- That's awesome.
So we see progress,
and I think we heard
that today in the keynote
and we will continue to
hear the progress around AI.
So the foundation, though,
we believe is somewhat weak.
And I think most of folks in the room
are probably struggling
with the architecture,
the interaction of these agents,
how they need to come together,
how you need to govern
agent-to-agent interaction,
the data that sits underneath.
What we've seen kind of in our experience
is about 50% of executives expect
autonomous decision making in three years,
which is a fairly
significant amount of money,
or excuse me, a percentage
from a Fortune, you know,
Fortune 500, Global 2000 perspective.
But 3% are implementing
orchestration today.
I think orchestration is a heavy topic
around how you're gonna move
from human into agent into the layers
that sit underneath and
kind of this API level.
But what we're seeing is the barriers
and where focus needs to be applied
over the coming 36 months, skill.
So we're spending a
significant amount of time,
money, and energy in upskilling,
and we believe everyone in the enterprise
should be a practitioner, right?
So we should all be practitioners.
- Absolutely.
- Are you seeing that
within Genworth?
- Absolutely.
You know, we've recently rolled
out to everybody, you know,
this kind of launching
service where, you know,
they can go classes, learn
their prompting, learn,
here's what these things
are doing in the background,
all that kind of stuff.
We also recently set up our AI CoE, right,
Center of Excellence.
And that's key, 'cause they can, you know,
kind of oversee all of the aspects
of where it's being used
to make sure, you know,
is this the right use case
or have you, you know,
have you put the right controls on this?
And, I mean, that's critical.
You know, data, you know, data,
we've always had data governance in place,
but you really need to shore them up
because you're going from
humans using the data
to autonomous operations using the data.
And when you see the end result, you know,
it doesn't show you,
here's the data that got me there, right?
You have to go looking for that.
- Sure.
- And so
making sure that governance is upfront
and making sure that, you know,
the AI is going to use the data correctly,
that's, you know, that's gonna be crucial.
- Yeah, one question
we get off and around,
so two questions for you.
One around, who's in the CoE?
- Yeah.
- Who are the participants?
And then two,
do you have a separate data governance
and AI governance team?
And what's the point of
convergence there that you see?
- So I, you know,
we do have separate data
and AI governance and,
you know, they work closely
together, of course.
What was the first question?
- Who sits in that
team, the AI governance?
So the AI CoE and the governance team,
who actually sits there?
Compliance, regulatory.
- So we actually have AI,
our IT is in the driver's seat there.
- Okay.
- But, you know, compliance
is always gonna have a say in-
- Sure.
- And, you know, in fact,
that's been a, you know,
one of those constant battles
that we've had this year
of getting them to approve things.
Just as, you know,
I had this conversation at
lunch today where I was saying,
you know, just taking the simple summary
of the call has taken us seven months.
And it took, like, 20
minutes of implementation.
And all the rest of it was trying
to get the lawyers to agree.
- Right.
- So, you know, they're gonna have a say,
but we don't want them in
the driver's seat. (laughs)
- Makes perfect sense.
Even in data governance,
you get the lawyers in the
room and you can't do anything.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- Ask for forgiveness sometimes.
But I think it's important and instructive
as you're on your journey, you know,
towards this concept of
agentic and autonomous.
Who are the participants?
And I think in any somewhat
new wave of technology,
there's always the
debate of centralization
versus decentralization versus federation.
And I think control
becomes an important tenet
and term as you think about,
so how much control do you
wanna exert over the tech-
- Yeah.
- Over the models,
over the use cases.
So do you guys struggle
with how much you wanna
kind of federate this out
to the business and capability?
- It's gonna be a learning
experience that as of now,
right now, the CoE is mostly
there for enablement, right?
They're there to help get
the business off the ground
with the use cases that
they wanna see, right?
Now, there's a lot of
people clamoring for it,
and we wanna make sure
we just get them through
and thinking about it the right way
so that we can accelerate it
and get that implemented for them.
But-
- That's great.
- You know, sometimes
they just wanna throw it,
you know, just turn the on switch,
right?
- Yeah.
- But, you know,
you definitely want to make sure
that you've set it up directly,
otherwise you're gonna
get all kinds of results.
- Sure.
That's where I think
the observability aspect
and what we've heard from AgentCore
and some of the new
releases from the keynote
are really important and the
learning process behind that.
So how you go from
observability to learning
will be really important
over the coming weeks
and months as AgentCore becomes, you know,
more mainstream as the platform of choice.
So why this concept of modernization,
and Mark touched on it,
and modernization isn't
just infrastructure
or data or models,
it's kind of the entire ecosystem
of people, process, and technology.
And those tenets haven't changed
over the course of the last, you know,
40 years of technology modernization.
But, you know, we believe modernization
is obviously this concept of
resiliency and scalability.
And we've talked about
that in data readiness.
So for Genworth, obviously making sure
that we understand our customer, right?
Understand the data.
- Yep.
- Master data becomes very
important in this conversation.
So within the Connect landscape,
you're seeing the experience of agent,
the experience to outcome,
but the data preparation and
unstructured data tagging
and labeling becomes really important.
So have you guys had to wrestle
with any of those problems?
- Sure.
And we're continuing to, you know?
With the modernization project
we undertook last year,
we set the foundation.
And so we really set up for the, you know,
here's all the data that
the callers are gonna have,
you know, here's, but it
was all from the mainframe.
Now we're getting all the soft data.
What letters did we send them,
you know, in the past month?
What calls have they made?
What, you know, what
did they need last time?
Who did they talk to?
And we need to make use
of all that data real time
when they call back.
And so, you know, and it's all about
making sure that it's set up,
it's accessible, and, yeah,
like you said, tagged properly, right?
- We were in a session earlier today,
and one of the Connect leaders said,
if the prompt or the
customer service reaction is,
you know, thanks for
calling, how can I help you?
- Yeah.
- You've already lost
the call.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So you should know why
people are looking to engage,
what their problems are,
the background behind it.
You know, it's like when my
cable goes out and I call
and the first thing they
ask me to do is, you know,
reset my router,
which I've now done four
times before I called, right?
Because what would you do when you-
- Yeah, that's the first thing.
- That's exactly right.
- Turn it off, turn it on.
- So that end-to-end experience
and understanding the problem,
having some kind of intuition behind it,
but trying to solve it end to end
through this agentic approach
I think is important.
- Yeah.
So skipping steps as it
relates to these pilots.
So I think most people
started with, you know,
single agent pilots, you
know, getting to multi-agent.
I think this concept of end-to-end agentic
across your primary workflows,
order to cash, record to report,
source to pay will be an evolution.
I think you're seeing many
people trying to focus on,
you know, the back and forth
of probabilistic versus deterministic.
And when it becomes deterministic,
how do you use in AWS
terms like lambda functions
to do that versus the
experience of, you know,
using something like AgentCore.
- Right.
- Or obviously Bedrock.
But do you guys kind of think
about the application of agents
and when it becomes more
business role driven
versus where you actually need the agent
to function and have intuition?
- Sure, we've been, you know,
we've been doing a lot of experimentation.
None of this is in our
production environment yet.
But, you know, if you think
about the IVR experience,
when somebody calls in,
the old approach and our
current production approach
is you have all these utterances
and they all point to a
number of cues, right?
It's very labor intensive
to update that list,
make sure it's, you know,
relevant and it's going to the right queue
and all that kind of stuff.
Well, now what we can do is we can say,
here are my queues,
here's what they can do.
Just take whatever the customer asked for,
send that through Bedrock,
and let Bedrock say,
here's the best place to send it.
And we find, you know, and
again, this is development,
but we're finding it very
reliable to get it to a queue
that can actually handle their call.
And that, you know, instantly, you know,
maximizes how many
utterances you can handle,
'cause it's infinite.
And, you know, if you have a new event
that the caller might call back about,
you can just put that in
one of the queues and say,
I take these kind of calls, and
then instantly it's updated.
- That's amazing.
- And that updates
your whole routing, so, you know,
the speed in which you
can react goes from,
you know, two weeks to two minutes.
- Have you, we talked about today
and yesterday with a few clients,
this concept of fine-tuning, right?
And I think fine-tuning the model
based on your semantic and
language, do you guys see that?
Are the foundational models
precise enough, right,
for the-
- For this, yeah.
For this particular use case
that I'm mentioning, yeah,
we're using a miniature model
to get it as fast as possible.
- Yep.
- Because you don't want
somebody waiting there, you know?
- Right.
- Listening to whole music.
So, and we found that
that has been just fine
for being able to accurately
get it to the right cue.
No tuning, just out of the box.
- That's pretty crazy.
- Yeah, it's pretty crazy.
- That's amazing.
- From what we used to have.
You know, prior to AWS, we were on Nuance.
Nuance takes that say anything main menu
and they compile it.
So all we received was a binary.
To update that binary,
you would go through a
back and forth process
that would be several months just to get,
can we add one phrase? (laughs)
So, yeah.
- So that kind of brings
to the last point of legacy systems.
So you had Nuance prior to,
obviously moving to Connect
is a different experience,
a different set of capabilities.
But how much did the
legacy either set you back,
or how much of that did
you need to prepare for-
- Right.
- Before unlocking
capabilities-
- So, yeah, so we were,
you know, we were not
on the newest version of Nuance either.
Ours was about 15 years.
- Makes it easier. I'm just kidding.
- Yeah, 15, well, it makes it easier,
'cause you just start with a-
- Just to turn it off.
Unplug it from the wall.
- Burn it down.
But yeah, you really do have
to restart at that point.
'Cause, you know,
none of it was portable
except for the utterances.
- Yeah.
- We were able to import
the 4,000 phrases,
but now we're gonna throw
'em out, so. (laughs)
But, yeah, so, you know,
legacy really was holding us back.
And, you know, we had identified that
and we had gone through several
iterations of, you know,
what do we want to do with the experience?
And it wasn't really until we identified,
you know, what's our North Star here?
And it started with that
customer experience.
How do we really, you
know, make the customer,
you know, satisfied when they call?
We don't necessarily
want them to call back,
you know, reduce the call with volume.
But we wanna make sure that
they had a good experience,
right, and so, you know,
within two months of
us rolling out Connect,
we saw our CSAT scores up 14 points.
- Yeah, that's amazing.
- Yeah.
And yeah, it's been transformative.
And the speed in which
we're able to react,
like I said, you know, being
able to implement changes,
you know, a week instead of a month or,
you know, whatever it be,
it's been fantastic.
- That's awesome.
So Mark's gonna talk, as he has,
for the better part of
the last 27 minutes,
about the Genworth journey.
But talk a little bit
about kinda this concept
of predictive, right, self-healing,
and maybe a little bit
about where you see the
journey next, right?
What's upcoming?
- Yeah.
So a lot of things of what
we're working on right now is,
again, on that predictive routing.
I mentioned kind of what
we're working on there with,
you know, take whatever
the customer has said,
what they've indicated to us,
and get an LLM to identify what queue
are they gonna need to go to?
What kind of help do they need?
The other thing we do is we see, you know,
did they just talk to
somebody 15 minutes ago?
Can we just connect them back to them?
Because that's, you know,
and a lot of times that's really helpful
'cause you don't have to
start from square one.
- Sure.
So the predictive
routing, the self-healing,
that's something that
we're working on right now
is we're looking at, okay,
how do we take our CloudWatch
data and identify, okay,
we seem to have some audio issues here
in the Philippines or in Belize.
How do we start to put in the
processes to get that fixed,
get that healing?
'Cause that's been a challenge for us as,
you know, some agents in far-off places
having audio issues or particular
agents having mic issues.
It'd be great to be able
to identify, hey, you know,
we're getting sound quality
issues out of this agent,
and reach out to them.
Don't wait for them to
reach out to the help desk.
So that's one thing that
we're working on now
is how do we utilize all
that data streaming in
to identify things upfront?
- That classification
problem, while basic, right,
but just classification and queuing
could make a huge difference
on kind of who takes
the call and resolution.
- Exactly. Exactly.
- Yeah.
- And if they call into
the help desk, you know,
they're gonna try debugging things for,
you know, 20 minutes.
That's 20 minutes the agent isn't off.
If we have already identified, hey,
the issue's your mic, fix your mic.
So this is a little bit about our journey.
We had 1,600 call center agents moved over
from our Avaya on-prem telecom.
So setting up how we built
our Connect flow is, you know,
identify the caller, find out,
you know, are they a real caller?
'Cause that still happens.
You still get spam
calls for a call center.
I don't know why.
It's like what do they hope to gain?
But you still get those.
So we actually-
- Competition, by the way.
- Yeah, exactly.
It's like, what is this?
So we've actually been
able to kind of just drop
all of those spam calls pretty
readily, which was great.
And really all we had to do is put a step
that would seem natural to a human,
but computers aren't gonna do it, right?
So identify the caller
call number, and again,
send it through the intelligent router.
Did they receive a
letter that's, you know,
asking them to change their
rates or change their options.
We're gonna get them straight
to a specialized agent.
We're gonna skip all this,
get them to an agent
because they have questions
and this isn't gonna answer it,
so let's just get them to an agent.
- Can I ask you a question on that?
So you're tying campaign data-
- Yeah.
- Right,
into kind of the call
center so you understand
or can have some level of
understanding why, right?
And through that why then routing them
to the best appropriate-
- Yeah.
So a lot of what's our
campaigns might be is, you know,
hey, we need to change the
rates in your state, right?
You're gonna go up monthly payment,
10% or whatever.
It's kinda like healthcare.
- Yep.
- And, you know,
that's obviously gonna be a
stressful call for the user,
but we can get them to the agent
that will give them options, right?
Like, we can keep your rates the same
and we'll just change
these options around and,
you know, in a lot of cases
solve their issue, right?
Like, maybe you didn't
really actually need
this type of care that
you have a rider on.
So, you know, we can
take that off for you,
keep you where you are.
Those sorts of decisions
that we can walk you through.
But, you know,
they'll have received a very scary letter
that they don't understand.
- There's a compassion-
- Yeah.
- To the approach, too, in there.
- Oh, yeah, of course, yeah.
We wanna make sure, you know,
it's never a fun conversation.
- Sure.
- Right?
And in a lot of cases, you know,
if you've seen Genworth's journey,
we went from, you know,
we were gonna be $16 billion under water
with some of these policies,
to now we're, you know, within one or two.
- Wow, all because of Connect-
- Over the past 10 years.
No.
- I'm just-
- (chuckles) Yeah, good call.
No, over the past 10 years
through these rate actions.
But you still, you're,
they're our customers.
We want to take care of them, right?
But we wanna make sure that
we are solvent and able to.
(laughs) So that's been,
it's been a journey.
But that's one case
where identifying the
caller early on in the queue
and not making them walk through
a whole lot of extra effort, you know,
that sort of thing can
really change the experience.
- Have the metrics changed?
So years ago, did some call center work.
I'm not, you are by no means an expert,
but things like average handling time,
first call resolution,
which just because
someone doesn't call back
doesn't mean you actually
resolve their problem,
right?
- That's true.
- I mean, they're more angry.
Like in healthcare, then
you follow, you know,
to CMS and nobody actually
wants that to happen.
So have you found the
metrics need to change
as you deploy these technologies?
- A lot of those metrics
have stayed the same.
- Okay.
- But, you know,
a lot of that hasn't changed yet.
We haven't really gotten,
we got the call routing in place, right?
We've got it easier to contact us.
Now we're moving on to
how do we make it easier
for the agent to help.
- Okay.
- And that's where we'll see
a lot of those improvements.
But, you know, from a net promoter score,
you know, obviously that has been a real,
they're very satisfied
talking to the Lex or, what,
I forget what voice we selected, right?
But that voice sounds a lot more friendly
than apparently what we had.
- Do you mind
taking a question, by the way?
- Sure, yeah. Absolutely.
- So you said before
that when they got a letter,
you verified that they got the letter.
- Yeah.
- More around what you mean,
because you said that AI
agents (speaks indistinctly).
My question is why.
Did you consider
(indistinct) or pilots go,
hey, let's give the AI some options-
- Yeah.
- And explain to them,
clarifies and says, well, you know,
you have this rate
where we do X, Y, and Z,
and see how (speaks indistinctly).
- So yeah, we have not, but that said,
we're very early in our
agent implementation.
Like, we're at the copilot
stage, right, phase one.
But I mean, as we move through it,
I think that's a fantastic place to look.
- A secondary piece as well.
- Sure.
- [Audience Member]
Which is if you haven't,
so you're saying you
haven't asked that yet.
I wonder if you might explore that.
Are you still using that same capability
to try those options,
(speaks indistinctly) or
copilot perspective where-
- Yeah.
- Okay,
maybe you're not telling
the customer these options,
but you're providing agents these options
from the system.
- Yeah. Yeah.
And that's certainly where
we're gonna put it first.
You know, one of our kind of
tenants right now is, you know,
don't force the customers to put up with,
you know, here are the AI options, right?
We've always all seen,
you know, the ChatGPT,
here's my opinion, right?
And it runs through the options.
We don't wanna put them
through that until it's ready.
So first step will be, like
you said, agent assist.
Present the relevant data to the agent
and get it in front of
them to present that.
But again, we're not there yet.
But definitely,
as we continue our journey
into the autonomous journey,
we will.
- I think it's a great option.
As you think about, again,
kind of the final response,
you know, agent-based, maybe
a little bit of risk there,
but reinforced learning,
like if the agent,
the human agent is the one
who's the arbiter of the decision
based on what they're
hearing from the human,
then they can make that decision
that goes back into the model.
So I think it's a really important point
and potentially a safer way to start
to roll this out as you get towards more-
- It's a great use case.
I'm gonna take that back.
- We talk about the AWS ecosystem.
So how has Connect fit
into the overall ecosystem
of AWS within Genworth?
What else sits out there across AWS?
- So AWS Connect
is definitely our biggest
implementation right now.
And we have the data to support it.
So we call it the enterprise data hub.
So those are the two
biggest implementations.
But then we have our customer websites
sitting in AWS right now.
Our, Pega, our customer assistant screens,
that's sitting in Amazon,
it's Pega's Amazon,
but it's still within the borders.
So most of our front-facing applications
that a customer would
deal with is in there.
So, you know, it really allows us
to do that data sharing
full circle, right?
If they, you know, go onto our website,
make an update, well,
the agent can already
know about that update
when they call, if they call.
And so that's something
that's important to us
is try to make that as
seamless as possible.
Again, harken back to our legacy days
where they make an update on the web
and it's gonna be like three days
before the agent even knows about it.
So, and if they call, they're
gonna be very confused.
And I've had many of those
conversations of, like,
yeah, I know we have web services,
but that's not, they're going
to the mainframe. (laughs)
- So that integrated approach-
- Yeah.
- What other integrations do you have
outside of the AWS ecosystem?
- We have some Azure
capabilities right now.
Most of that right now
is our internal systems,
like our analytical actuarial systems.
So none of them that need
that real-time connection.
Most of our real-time connections
are happening in Amazon right now.
- Great. That's great.
- What do we got here?
So from a capability perspective, right,
as you think about value
creation within gen AI
and kind of the current
versus future use cases.
So you talked about summarization.
- Summarization. Yeah.
We just got that rolled
out full agent-wide,
just the tail end of last month.
And it's funny, it took us, like I said,
seven months to get
through that compliance.
- Five days of development.
- 400 meetings.
- Within two weeks,
they were like, "Oh, yeah,
you can roll that out
to all your agents now."
So we started with two call flows.
Now you can just roll
it out with all of 'em.
It's like, okay.
Yeah. So like I said, snowball effects.
- Yep.
- You get one approval,
you prove it right.
It's really hard to demo with fake data.
- Sure.
- And that's something that's,
so it's really hard for
compliance to be like,
oh, yeah, that'll be fine.
It's like, but they don't
see the real call, right?
And so that's what they're
really nervous about.
So being able to pilot it
with a couple real call
flows within two weeks,
they were like, "Yes, this is fine.
We like this."
And the richness of the agent notes
that they'll have available
to them has gone up tenfold.
- Right.
- Like,
'cause now we're getting
like a paragraph of text,
4,000 characters or more.
Whereas before, you know,
in their call wrap up,
you know, they type a sentence,
maybe two.
- Sure.
- And now we have like a full rundown
of what the agent did in summary form.
It's been fantastic.
Agent assist,
you know, that's something
that we're experimenting with now,
but
auto QA is also going
live, I think, in January.
And one thing that we
talked about at launch
is kind of the limitations of the auto QA
of only having 10 AI actions on there.
So hopefully that gets raised soon
so we can do more and more
with it because, you know,
I think that's gonna be a really huge,
what they told us about today
was being able to give back
a training report, right?
And being able to say, here's
where your agents need,
you know, some extra training,
some extra validation.
Give that back to the
supervisor right away.
And, you know, it's not
something they have to go
and discover over months
of monitoring calls.
They can-
- More advanced observability.
It's limited to 10 today?
- The auto QA is like questions
that the AI can identify-
- Okay.
- In a transcript.
- The quality course.
- Yeah.
- [Audience Member] Yeah.
So there,
it was actually one of the
discussions I think yesterday,
and apparently it is a big interest.
A lot of people said they can raise that.
So I think there's some
discussion to that end.
I think (speaks indistinctly).
- Yeah.
- So the bottom line,
you really need more than 10.
There were some more where they talk
about classified goals accordingly or,
you know (speaks indistinctly).
- Yeah, great.
- That's very helpful. Yeah.
- Yeah.
- The other thing we're
gonna do early next year
is start experimenting
with, again, chat bots,
we don't wanna stick a chat
bot in front of our customers,
but we're okay with it
on our employees, right?
Let's experiment with them.
So, you know, our internal
help desk, you know,
being able to reset a
password, it can ask questions,
you know, it can go
fetch the magic questions
and you can answer 'em and then
it can reset your password.
You know, that's, and it can
do a lot more than that too.
'Cause it can go through the
entire SOP archive and say,
try these things.
And if that doesn't work, okay, well,
we'll go ahead and escalate your call.
So that's something that
we're about to embark on,
and very excited about that.
- On the SOP extraction,
could you just expand on that?
So are you using it in archive or actually
to help create SOPs for processes
of which that are yet to be fully defined?
- So currently pointed at the archive.
- Yep.
- And then
it can offer those
suggestions real time, right?
But to your point,
I see us being able to then say,
okay, now point it at, you know,
successful interactions
that it's because we
have all the transcripts,
create SOPs based on what actions
were taken that were successful.
And we're actually trying to do that
on the customer side too.
Help them develop their knowledge base
based on successful outcomes
and have our knowledge archive for that.
And then of course our knowledge archive
for the agents is also
gonna be AI-powered.
So they can ask questions
if they have questions
come up during the call.
They don't have to go surfing
through the knowledge archives
and try to find the right
keyword to get through task.
And that's a big win.
- Have you found the barrier
being somewhat of the guinea pig, right,
in the organization
starting, has compliance,
they have a better understanding.
I think some of the barriers
are the fear of the unknown.
- Oh, yes.
- Right, the starting point.
So you don't obviously
wanna be on the cover
of the Wall Street Journal as
everybody has said for years,
but has the barrier towards entry
and understanding for
compliance, for legal,
for regulatory dropped?
- It's, yeah, very much so.
And we've seen it, you know,
the tide shift almost overnight.
And it is about just
being able to prove, like,
hey, these things are useful.
And it's not just about
doing your job faster,
it's about being able
to do your job, right?
Like, a lot of those agent calls
where they would've had to
go to a knowledge archive,
if they can't find the article,
can't find that,
it ends in a bad experience
for the customer.
It ends up the, you know,
customer didn't get what
they needed, but, you know,
the agent found an article
that was able to get rid
of the caller, get to my next call.
- Right.
- So we don't want those,
right, so enable that experience,
enable the human connection
between call center agent,
customer service rep,
let's just call 'em reps.
'Cause too many agents being thrown-
- Right, that's right.
- Between the rep and the customer.
Make sure that we've enabled
that human connection
to occur naturally.
- That's wonderful.
Taking a step back,
the business case that you guys had
when you first sat out.
- Yeah.
- What were the primary metrics and how,
I know you mentioned CSAT
increasing significantly,
which is fantastic.
What else did you start with,
and where are you seeing
kind of the end state at this point?
- The biggest use case that we had
was our ability to react to
things that are happening.
Like, being able to react to a letter
that we had to send out.
Not even just the rate action letters.
You know, one of our
partners was a victim of the,
it was the transfer software
that just a couple years
ago got hacked and released.
Well, they were a victim, we weren't,
but they used it and so some of our data
was exposed that way, right?
So they got these strange
letters that said, hey,
this company you never
heard of had a breach
and so now your data's out there, right?
And so when that happened
they came to my team,
telecom team and said, all right,
we're getting all these calls
and they're coming into
all these different queues.
Is there anything you can do with the,
you know, say anything menu?
No, no, no, no.
That would take months. We'd send it off.
We'd have a conversation with Nuance
and we'd have to get a
compiled version back.
There's no way. There's no way.
So we, you know,
eventually put in some, like,
hack into it where we could,
you know, send certain
volumes of calls off,
but we couldn't react, right?
And not having the ability to react
to present day events was a big use case.
And we told them straight up,
like, our system right
now isn't in a state
where you can react like that.
But there is this system
over here that you can.
We've been looking at it.
- Right.
- We really want it.
So that was a big shift for,
for the business to say,
aha, there is a reason that
we want this technology.
So it's right.
It's really, you know,
both sides really do
want the same outcomes.
They just don't talk the same language.
- Was there a goal towards
driving the per unit cost
of interaction down too?
Was that a metric that
you guys were looking at?
I mean, there's always those
stats that are tracked.
I don't think we drive 'em quite
as hard as other companies.
- Okay.
- You know, 'cause it depends.
I, you know, prior to Genworth,
I worked at AOL, and boy,
did we drive those metrics hard.
You know, the only
calls you let go on long
are the ones that retain customers.
So, but for Genworth, it
really is about, you know,
trying to solve customer's
problem on that first call.
First call resolution's a big one.
And, you know, we do average handle time,
all those type of stats,
but we don't drive them
quite as hard as others.
- Cool. Wonderful.
We'll talk, we've three minutes left
and we have to be on time.
So the leadership shift, right?
We're seeing, you know,
this going from obviously
the board and the C-suite.
So leaders are treating this concept
of agents and agentic AI,
you know, as a capability
that kind of rewires the
concept of how work gets done.
I think it's really
important to think about
how work gets done and how
work gets done with agents.
And with agents,
I mean these bounded systems
with context and perception
and memory and these
multi-step capabilities
with coordination of data.
So really important in
the proper guardrail.
So really important as
you go on this journey,
redefine how work gets done.
This agent and human
interaction becomes important.
And, you know,
these production workflows
with observability,
I think the most interesting
thing, we sat down with the,
one of the agent core leaders today,
very focused on observability, right?
Being able in a regulatory environment,
being able to produce the why,
so the input and the output and
how these agents interacted,
that becomes critically important
in any regulatory experience.
But just as you're trying
to educate the masses
and your leadership team as to
how you derive this outcome.
But I think successful execution follows
kind of this consistent pattern
where organizations
start with high impact,
low complexity use cases.
They create the wins similar
to what Mark mentioned.
They kind of codify that
into these reusable kits,
prompts, guardrails, data hooks,
and then they scale that vertically
where kind of P&L impact concentrates.
And that point isn't accumulating
proof of concepts, right?
It's actually compounding the knowhow
and building more and more
capability and outcomes.
So I think that's really
important. We'll keep moving.
We're gonna go to the end if that's okay.
'Cause we have one minute.
So I think key takeaways for us,
so we believe, you know,
this concept of the autonomous enterprise
over the next five years,
everyone who will have
some level of autonomy.
So whether it's in sales conversions
and what we're seeing in, you know,
getting a point and a half increase,
software development, productivity,
there was some capabilities
that were rolled out today
that I think are important.
Software development life cycle,
agent development life cycle.
We're seeing about 35% improvement.
But starting, ensuring that
you have the proper use cases.
You have, you start with copilot,
you think about single agent,
you get towards this multi-agent.
But as you start this journey
of kind of multi-agent and agentic,
really doing so thoughtfully,
thinking with first principle, right?
Taking kind of a step
back and understanding
how you're gonna redefine
the enterprise end to end.
So for us at Genpact,
being a business operator for our clients,
we have firsthand experience
of what that last mile needs to be.
So we can kind of
challenge the status quo.
But what we've learned
is do it responsibly.
Make sure you have the right
safeguards in place and,
you know, over time
this kind of test learn
and continue to accumulate
knowledge is compounding.
And that compounding effect
becomes really, really important.
So with that, Mark,
I'll leave it to you to maybe
give us the grand close.
(Mark laughs)
- Yeah, so again, you know,
for your journey, set your North Star.
Get your business leaders
to support that journey with you.
It's a partnership.
And, you know,
make sure that you have the
proper governance frameworks
and, you know, the rest
will follow much easier
after proper foundation is set up.
- Awesome. Well, thank you.
We appreciate everybody sitting in.
Hopefully you were in the right spot.
So you learned a little bit
around kind of Mark's journey
and what we're seeing in the marketplace.
Come see us at our happy
hour at six o'clock
at Trattoria Reggiano.
So thanks, and I hope
everybody has a great show.
(audience applauding)